Чого чекати Україні від Польщі, де на парламентських виборах
переможець фактично… програв?
Чому не спрацювали антиукраїнські гасла?
І що буде із соціальними виплатами для біженців з України?
Формально вибори виграла правляча партія "Право і Справедливість",
набравши понад 35 відсотків голосів, але це зовсім не означає,
що їм вдасться зберегти владу - для цього їм бракує достатньо сильного
коаліційного партнера. Більшість місць у парламенті в сумі набрала опозиція:
блок "Громадянська коаліція" Дональда Туска, коаліція лібералів та аграріїв "Третій шлях"
та партія "Лівиця". Саме ці політичні сили, за оцінками політичних оглядачів,
і формуватимуть уряд.
Найвірогідніше наступним прем'єром стане досвідчений проєвропейський політик Дональд Туск.
Він вже очолював польський уряд у 2007-14 роках, а потім був головою Європейської Ради.
Очікується, що за його правління мають покращитися відносини
Польщі з Євросоюзом, а також з Україною.
Меншою мірою будуть гостро стояти на порядку денному питання історичної пам'яті
попри те, що для поляків це питання важить більше, ніж для українців,
як свідчать результати опитувань. Звісно, залишаться частина тих,
хто будуть продовжувати експлуатувати це питання.
Однак це явно буде не мейнстрімом у новому уряді.
Що стосується болісного питання українського зерна, то воно, ймовірно,
залишиться на порядку денному, тому що і у новій коаліції будуть представники політичних сил,
які воюють за серця аграріїв як електорату.
Це частина "Третьої сили", яка, ймовірно, увійде в коаліцію.
Тут прогрес буде меншим, хоча, з іншого боку, ми можемо сподіватися на те,
що вплив Європейського Союзу все ж таки позначиться на позиціях поляків.
Явка на цих виборах встановила історичний рекорд для Польщі, склавши 74 відсотки.
Це значно більше, ніж попередній найвищий показник у 1989 році,
коли країна "прощалася" з комунізмом. Тоді було близько 63 відсотків.
Особливо високою явка була у великих містах, а також серед молоді.
Завдяки цьому "Громадянська коаліція" Туска набрала на понад півтора мільйона голосів більше,
ніж на попередніх виборах. Тоді як за "Право і Справедливість" проголосували майже
стільки ж, як чотири роки тому.
Союзник "ПіС" - крайня права "Конфедерація", відома своїми антиєесівськими
та антиукраїнськими гаслами - набрала лише 7 відсотків.
Її риторика проти Брюсселя, Берліна і Києва не спрацювала.
"Конфедерація" виступала надто агресивно, і це мобілізувало тих, хто підтримує опозицію.
Також відбувся, як кажуть оглядачі, своєрідний "політичний канібалізм",
адже правляча партія "Право і Справедливість" під час виборчої кампанії
ще більш радикалізувалася і тим самим "з'їла" голоси "Конфедерації".
Крім того, у польському суспільстві відбулося усвідомлення спільного ворога, яким є Росія,
а також того, що без вільної України не буде вільної Польщі і що попри дрібні суперечки
треба зберігати єдність у принципових питаннях.
На міжнародній арені Туск намагатиметься покращити відносини Польщі
з нашими ключовими партнерами. І не лише з Німеччиною, Європейським Союзом,
а й з українцями, з якими нинішня влада посварилася незадовго до виборів.
Тож це буде велика зміна. Але налагодження відносин з ЄС, зокрема, вимагатиме внутрішніх змін,
а саме відновлення незалежності судової системи,
відновлення верховенства права, що є умовою для ЄС,
щоб вивільнити фінансування для Польщі.
Втім, зробити це буде непросто. Польща нині надзвичайно поляризована.
Фактично є дві Польщі: яка підтримує чинну владу і яка вимагає змін.
Навіть ставши прем'єром, Туску буде складно втілювати реформи.
Адже президент Польщі Анджей Дуда - виходець з партії "Право і справедливість".
І як глава держави має право вето. Тож він може блокувати ініціативи нової влади,
а для подолання вето у нової коаліції забракне голосів.
До того ж, під контролем партії "Право і справедливість" залишаться Національний банк,
Конституційний суд та деякі інші важливі держоргани.
Тож, як каже опозиція, очищення країни після восьми років демократичного відкату буде складним.
Багато інституцій - важливих інституцій - все ще знаходяться в руках
партії "Право і справедливість". Функціонери та їхні прихильники нікуди не зникнуть.
Тому буде дуже важко показати людям, які голосували за опозицію, одразу якусь помітну зміну.
І люди можуть бути розчаровані, якщо зміни не відбудуться швидко,
і вони не побачать там чогось відчутного, що справді впливає на їхнє життя.
Те, що нинішня опозиція має зробити, - це мати програму, кілька речей,
які вони зможуть виконати і показати, скажімо, через три місяці,
протягом 100 днів уряду. Це дуже важливо.
Теоретичний шанс залишитися при владі у правлячої нині партії Качинського теж є.
На думку оглядачів, "Право і справедливість" буде до останнього триматися за владу,
намагаючись переманити на свій бік депутатів з інших партій.
Вони їм потрібні фактично для одного принципового голосування -
за "нового-старого" прем'єра Моравецького. Швидше за все президент Дуда першим подасть
його як кандидатуру від партії, що набрала найбільше голосів на виборах.
Утім, переважна більшість оглядачів та експертів сходяться на тому,
що це навряд чи вдасться реалізувати і що Польща швидше за все отримає нового прем'єра,
а саме - Дональда Туска. Він позитивно налаштований до надання допомоги Україні
та українським біженцям, але бюджетні виплати зазнають змін.
Ймовірно, будуть переглядатися умови перебування українців,
особливо в соціальному плані там, де йшлося про підтримку для тих, хто без роботи.
Туск і його партнери по коаліції не приховують того, що питання треба в якийсь спосіб вирішувати.
Хоча, можливо, не так войовничо і радикально, як робили це "ПіСівці".
Але це об'єктивний процес. Подібні процеси відбуваються й в інших сусідніх державах.
І в Румунії, і в Словаччині. Але, з іншого боку, кількість українців, які перебувають у Польщі,
не рівнозначна кількості українців, які потребують соціальної допомоги.
Справа в тому, що інтегруватися до польського суспільства українцям виявилося простіше,
ніж в інших країнах. Вони доволі легко знаходять роботу, вони виступають вже навіть
інвесторами для польської економіки, вкладаючи в нерухомість,
відкриваючи свій малий бізнес. Звісно, знайдеться сегмент тих, на кому це позначиться,
але цей сегмент не буде більшістю.
На думку експертів, новий уряд вдасться сформувати не раніше листопада-грудня.